two-time Super Bowl winner and future
pro Football Hall of Famer first ballot
guy Peyton Manning how are you Peyton
hey rich well thanks for thanks for
calling in it was a blast watching it
what was it like playing it Peyton what
was that like man well obviously the
weather wasn't wasn't part of the plan
both Tom and I got there Thursday night
and got to play Friday and Saturday and
a couple practice rounds with Tiger and
fill-in the weather was just perfect and
then on Sunday the heavens opened up so
that wasn't really what I was thinking
about I was pretty nervous just thinking
about playing in perfect weather much
less playing in the rain and kind of
trying to keep the club from falling out
but maybe in some ways it kind of helped
relax a little bit because you're kind
of your expectations kind of lower a
little bit at that point but as I said
after the match any time you get to go
behind the ropes in somebody else's
field by playing with Tiger and Phil you
know I've got the years ago hosted
Saturday Night Live behind the ropes
you're seeing how these actors and
comedians go about their craft I've
always enjoyed those experiences and
what a great seat Tom and I had watching
Phil and Tiger do their thing as you
said 20 million dollars I mean that was
the real winner that's real money it's
kind of get to some organizations that
are helping out people who need it that
was the best part about it well I mean
again it's not the first time you've won
in the rain in the state of Florida
obviously that that you've had that
feeling before it was a similar it was a
similar start rich - to my last kind of
event in Florida in the rain you're of
course referring a Super Bowl 41 yes and
I've waited all my life and nine years
in the NFL to get to that game and you
have all these dreams of how it's going
to start explaining devin hester runs
the opening kickoff back for a touchdown
and i throw an interception on my first
so my first drive into the
no no trees and having to have Tiger go
in there and find it and tell me how to
drive that was that reminded me a Super
Bowl 41 I mean that's I'm sitting at
home and I'm thinking like that is just
the last thing I would ever want to do
certainly havoc nationally-televised
with Charles Barkley able to comment and
chime in at any moment in time but you
were able to straighten it out Tom
however took a little bit longer I've
been I've played before with playing
partners or people in my group who are
struggling what was that like watching
that from your perspective you know
tiger and I'd kind of kind of had some
had some things in Dan ready for you
know Phil and and Tom you know Tiger you
know I wanted to bring his three US Open
trophies with him in car in the parking
lot and had me to marry one of him carry
one and you know go ask it still wanted
to kill you the others got scratched but
he went with Canada the gold-medal wide
you know to fill about a permanent mark
my ball with one of our US Open gold
medals so I had a couple more for Tom as
the attire but when the golf didn't
start out so well we kind of called an
Omaha just didn't feel that was
appropriate at the time and I could
relate and I was with them and and it's
it's it's no fun when you're playing by
yourself and in those conditions and not
hitting it well and so I thought he
handled it well and obviously kind of
got back on track when he hit that
awesome shot into the hole so I thought
he was a troop of the whole time and
both both he and I were out of our
comfort zone the entire time I never
felt called whole moving one time the
entire entire day until it was probably
over but I was certainly glad we did it
Peyton Manning here on the Rich Eisen
show what concentration level does this
game require that makes it even tougher
than what you did professionally yeah I
mean for a long time I tried to
eight football to golf and you know in
football rich I kind of knew how to fix
it right if things didn't in that Bears
game right I didn't start off well but I
kind of knew how to fix it right and you
start going to plays that you that you
know really well and taking your check
downs and kind of you're getting some
completions and get your confidence
going now you're back throwing the ball
down the field
so football I could fix it golf I've
never really been able to fix it I kind
of always hope it's hope it's my day
that day it just kind of tended on how
you're hitting it and although I did
make some improvements the other day
it's just it's just different I mean you
can try harder and football I think and
it can it can work for you golf it
almost works the opposite way the harder
you you strain and kind of stress and
grind sometimes the worse you play you
swing harder and you you missed putts
and so it's a completely different game
just thinking about the amount of
repetitions that Phil and Tiger I've had
on the golf course hitting all those
shots I can relate that as Tom can to
throw on a football so it's just
different and when you're out of your
comfort zone it makes it even harder
what's the best tip Tiger gave you you
know I didn't ask for a whole lot of
advice just because it's just different
and then the way if the ball is just not
really something that I can relate to
much less anybody but you know on the
alternate shot it's a little like
playing football you have a teammate and
you don't want to hang them out you
don't want to lead a receiver high
across the middle right I don't want to
you know put Tiger Woods in bad
positions but it's a little more
comforting comforting knowing that you
can hit it anywhere around the Greens
rich and he can get up and down you know
put you in for a tap-in and I mean one
time I don't you heard the exchange I
hit a drive and so Tiger was going to be
219 yards out and he's like I got this I
got this I've never heard my friends in
Denver say yeah I got their hits 280
yards out it's just not something I'm
used to hearing right in my normal golf
game but that's when you kind of know
you're playing with the best in the
world and that certainly May
a little more relaxed so on the flipside
then Peyton okay you have accomplished
so much in life this is a great set up
here
you've accomplished so much in life
where does sneaking in a twenty-foot
real deal birdie no net anything real
deal birdie to win a hole for you and
Tiger Woods on national television as
you did in the fourth hole on Sunday
where does that rank for you I'll throw
it up there and I have to give my my
partner a great assist I mean not only
is he the the greatest golfer of all
time he is by far the best caddie and
green reader ever in history I mean you
talk about pressure on those putts
because he tells you hit it right here
at this speed and it'll go again I mean
his ability to read those greens and I
think he reads a lot of his greens
obviously when he's playing probably
gets confirmation from you know Joey his
teddy so but you feel like you're
getting a really good read and I could
just hit it to that spot so that felt
good you know knowing my partner was
like seven feet away for birdie himself
that's not like he was going to make it
that probably helped me relax a little
bit but it was definitely a team effort
and it always feels good when you see
one go in the hole I mean that that I
was just that I really for a moment put
myself in your shoes saying that would
be the greatest thing I've ever done I
mean of all time that it goes right in
and it's just again it's no candy that
was real you fired it at the pin you hit
it from where you landed and you got it
in the hole and you just to turn to
Tiger Woods and say you can pick yours
up I got it I mean no one you can tell
her pick that up that was probably the
best part about it I got you tiger
don't worry it's gonna be the greatest I
mean that's Dow my god I was rooting for
you right there Peyton Manning here on
the Rich Eisen show
so tonight on NBCSN your SNL hosting gig
from March 24 2007 is going to be
re-aired at 8 Eastern 7 central what are
your recollections of that night Peyton
well it's funny I was I was thinking
about it just the other day because
someone someone said you know send me a
social media post of me throwing the
footballs kids
waste get and they it subbed the kids
faces for Tom Brady's and phil
Mickelson's so I'm taking Phil in Palma
these footballs it was pretty good
pretty good almost as good as kind of
the Instagram post at Tom started out
the match trash-talking so I was
thinking about it and I get asked about
that a lot rich and I told this before
you know I wasn't really nervous because
it's because it was live and I was used
to doing live and used to probably screw
it up live a lot on Sunday afternoons
but but you also have a week to prepare
and you have kind of rehearsals right
you don't have that in golf but that one
particular skin was was the most out of
the box for me it you know it kind of
was I felt a little over the edge and I
was talking to the guys I was like my
mom's gonna be so disappointing when she
sees this it's like look your charitable
it's a spoof of you know honey will hate
that's why it's gonna be funny you know
but you got to be all in I mean you got
to whack these kids right in the face
this is Amy's Hamburg who's kind of my
coach on this and so he finally gets me
to say oh I'm in part and we're doing it
and these kids are there their parents
are out there watching and I finally
just said no I just can't I can't do it
i mean the parents are watching me pick
these kids in the head and then right as
we were about to kind of cancel it one
of the parents literally runs out and
tells the director no no I want to hit
my kid in the face and I will do it I
will knock your kid out thank you for
giving me your play
singing permission and after that I was
oh god I think we lost him again changed
after that so oh man so but you needed
your arm twisted eventually when they
when they when they gave you that when
they gave you that as an idea you needed
to have your arm twist a little bit
first
oh I certainly had I certainly had some
bad reservation and you know I mean I
guess I see the concept and it's one
thing when you're you know they picking
like you know picking the car and you
know and those kind of things but you
know I remember the guys like this treat
these kid like the rookie wide receivers
with really bad attitudes I was like
okay all right I could go there I can
find that place you know I
I know those receivers that think they
know it all and they're wearing their
College Bowl gear and their combine gear
out there and locker room I can go that
spot but still you know and you get
reminded this kids nine years old you're
telling it cute girl in a cute 9 year
old and a pink sweater pink watch the
Blitz I was definitely out of my comfort
people are still talking about it again
it'll be on the air tonight on NBCSN for
people to check out and comment hey
before I let you go just a couple of
quick things your brother's on Twitter
now Eli comes out of the box with a
reference to Hoosiers and then in
response to Brady giving him a little
bit of grief drops Caddyshack a very
very impressive beginning for y'all the
blobstore movie references Hoosiers
Caddyshack I'm an Eli and I Cooper can
probably tell you every single line from
Hoosiers and Caddyshack so ok yeah
strong out of the strong out of the
blocks for the little brother does that
mean you're next are you joining when
you don't hold your breath I wouldn't
hold your breath you know I'm still you
know I used to have a flip following up
until a couple years ago over it so I
gotta catch it up come on
but you're but you're still seeing
people are sending you said people are
sending you stuff your are you
you out there looking yet you see what
people are saying are you one of those I
keep up a little bit you know but I'm
probably not as not as up to date as
crowd everybody else no I mean I'm until
or and if that was kind of I was a tiger
and I said you know when early on the
four of us kind of had a group text and
we kind of said wow it's always been a
goal for me and Tiger to feed a couple
of roles grammars it was really high on
our bucket list so but so I'm probably a
little bit old school that way I lived a
long time without it and before he ever
existed so I guess I kind of think I can
probably keep keep surviving without it
that's I bet so and last one for you at
Peyton is just everyone I get this all
the time I'm sure you do too
certainly when we see what you you know
how obviously comfortable you are
talking and being yourself at a
microphone do you have any desire at any
point to call games to be a broadcaster
I know you've had opportunities I'm
wondering if that is still something
that would be of interest to you at some
point you know said that no forever I've
said I said no to to this year it just
doesn't doesn't feel like the right time
and and I hate sort of kind of having
this sort of well check with me next
year tight deal but that's really how I
approach this the chapter I just you
know I believe in taking a year to time
that's kind of what he'll I was doing
you know he's taking this year off it's
not really the way he wanted to start
he's living in quarantine he's home he's
teaching his eight-year-old his
nine-year-old daughter common
denominators god bless my niece you know
knowing why his teaching skills Wow
but you know so that's what I've tried
to do and yeah I don't really have a
five-year plan or a ten-year plan I hear
people say that I love playing football
I loved everything about it and I just
tried to ease into this second chapter
by keeping myself busy keeping myself
stimulated creating a lot of time for
family and if you see things I haven't
had a chance to do so
look I love watching the games rich I
love going to games we still got all the
Broncos games I get the Colts games I
kind of fight catch myself sort of
analyzing a game in my head when I'm
watching it I kind of always did that as
a player when you watched other games
you sort of played him in your mind and
so I don't do it quite to the extent
that I'm not playing but I kind of I
still enjoy doing it I enjoy listening
to you know Chris Collinsworth and Tony
and Troy Aikman and all the good
broadcasters that are doing their job
and of course you guys like Jim and Al
and Bill blocker or fun to listen to but
just not not in the cards for me right
now but can't really say never for you
know forever so in the meantime we'll
just compete with Romo on the golf
course now because we could see it we
see it no chance
hey Tony's got serious game and so you
know Tony's closer to fulfill and and
and Tiger than me and Tom all on the
golf side so he's got that figured out
so I'm gonna stay right in my way I'm
gonna stay with my Tuesday golf game
group here in Denver and you know some
high handicappers and low handicappers
but I will stay right in my way we'll go
hit him straight and thanks for the time
Peyton you are the man send my best to
your family spend my best to your
parents to your family and everybody
hope everybody's happy and healthy and
safe hey rich stay safe
all the best right back at you that's
Peyton Manning right here in the Rich
Eisen show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here